[Music]
that's a movie
it is yeah it's
it's pretty hard to discern between real
life and the cinema when i'm there
this is very confusing
what
i don't go to the cinema because my life
is cinema it's a movie yeah
especially when i'm at the dmv yeah i
don't get why people like write out
movies when you can just film real life
yeah exactly
because like
writing something that happens in real
life is stupid you can just film real
life yeah
yeah yeah exactly
i couldn't yeah couldn't have said it
better myself so that's how i feel about
going to the dmv
um
you hype i'm super hyped man it's gonna
be a crazy day i'm gonna go there
take a written test [ __ ] yeah when's the
last time you did that
last quarter
no you know what it was it was like it
was pretty recent
because every time yeah every time my
visa expires i have to go back and get a
new license
because that's when they set it to
expire is when your visa expires
because they're kind of like
time to go yeah america likes to do
renewing you know america likes doing
that [ __ ] yeah exactly
yeah they really do all right
what's the date say on there oh
probably time to get out huh time for
you to get the [ __ ] out
and i keep i keep renewing i keep
getting new visas they're like what you
[ __ ]
now you got the green card damn okay so
i gotta go back get a new license
and uh but the last time i did the last
time i did this
i don't know how i don't know
what service this is
i don't know who this is
but my business manager was like oh we
got a guy a dmv guy
did i tell you about this no
i was like what does that mean
and they're like just go
we made your appointment for you go in
there
and meet this guy so okay
go and meet this guy
he like took he like guided me through
the dmv okay
i still had to do all the dmv [ __ ] wait
for my number to be called everything
but he like knows people there
he's like friendly with the kathy and
he's that guy that actually makes those
jokes got it like how's your husband
how's the thing going and they like give
him special treatment
so he like got me through way faster
wow yeah
isn't that a crazy thing that exists wow
so i'm meeting him again
and he also said he's like so what do
you do and i was like oh i uh you know
make youtube videos and podcasts and
uh this was back when
i was doing real bros and i was like i'm
also doing this show right now called
real bros of simi valley and he was like
what's that about
and i was like oh my my character is
like basically this like
just like ultra douche and he was like
oh see not back then
and i was like oh for sure i don't even
know you man
me personally i wouldn't take this level
of disrespect
but you're providing me a great service
right now so i'm not gonna get mad at
you for that so the club promoter for
the dmv
negged you in front of the club yes and
then took you through yeah wow
i guess he is kind of a promoter isn't
he he's a club promoter yeah he is
it's going up tonight i got 10 slots at
the dmv i can get you in
hit me up dm me now
you gotta breaks going quick
yo yo uh
nathan i'm coming through to the dmv
today am i all good yeah bring five
girls
[Laughter]
all right for sure
damn
just pull up with five ladies
he's like yeah for sure ladies nice to
meet you
and you're over there taking a written
test
yeah
this guy's fingering your family
what
what
i don't know you just like bring your
mom and your aunt and [ __ ] yeah
he's just like
getting in there
it's
mm-hmm
you know trying to
trying to mak on the family yeah yeah
that's sick though is this yeah i get
bottle service at the dmv yeah
though yeah it's pretty fire
is this dude yeah i can walk you through
10 grand
when this dude called you a douche like
is he a douche
um is he is he a tool
he's a no he said you know what i'm
gonna avoid
saying anything about him until after
this experience is done today
he was a nice guy
little little little yeah i don't know a
little different yeah
it said some things that i was like
[Music]
you know
this was weird yeah um
and then yeah like halfway through i'm
just imagining what things he said to
you now
you're an actor
oh so you don't have to act then if
you're being a douche bag nice
about a facelift anytime